in this video we're going to think about
the economic profit of a monopoly of a
monopoly firm
and to do that we're going to draw our
standard price
and quantity axes
so that's
quantity and this is price
and this is going to of course be in
dollars
and we can first think about the demand
for this monopoly firm's product and the
demand curve would look similar to other
demand curves we've seen multiple times
that at a high price people wouldn't
want a lot wouldn't be demanding a lot
and then at a lower price as price goes
lower people are going to demand a
higher and higher quantity the market
will demand a higher and higher quantity
so that might be the demand curve now
what's interesting about
any imperfectly competitive firm in the
extreme case is a monopoly is what the
marginal revenue curve looks like given
this demand curve
in a perfectly competitive firm the
marginal revenue curve is equal to the
demand curve and in that situation it's
actually a horizontal line but here
because when the monopoly firm reduces
price it doesn't just reduce it on that
incremental unit it would be typical
that would have to reduce its price on
all of the units and we've studied this
in other videos you have a marginal
revenue curve that would go down faster
than the demand curve it would look
something like this and if this is
unfamiliar to you i encourage you to
watch some of those videos that go into
depth why this is happening so it's a
monopoly or actually any imperfectly
competitive firm its marginal revenue
curve will go down faster than the
demand curve so what would be a rational
quantity for this firm to produce well
to think about that we have to think
about its marginal cost curve so it's
marginal cost curve the typical way we
often think about it is at first you get
some economies of scale but then you
start having coordination costs and
maybe some diseconomies of scales your
inputs start getting more expensive and
so your marginal cost curve might look
something like that
and the rational quantity you produce is
as long as your incremental revenue for
every unit is higher than your
incremental cost for every unit you
would want to produce more and more and
more and more until the point that your
marginal cost is equal to your marginal
revenue and so the rational quantity to
produce right over here would be right
over there i'll do that q i could call
that q for the firm i could also call
that q sub m because we're doing a
situation where the firm is at least on
from the producer side it is the market
is the only producer it's a monopoly
but what's the price here
well to know that we just have to look
at the demand curve at this quantity the
price
is right over here
so the price is right over here once
again we could call that the market
the market price
and so something interesting has
happened here for the monopoly firm in a
perfectly competitive firm
where the marginal cost and demand
curves intersect that's what dictated
the demand because the demand curve and
the marginal revenue curve were the same
but here we are now producing a quantity
less than that we're producing a
quantity where price is greater than
marginal cost you can see it right over
there that this quantity price is
greater than marginal cost and so you
can view this difference right over here
as kind of a markup that is possible for
a monopoly firm to do that would not be
possible with a perfectly competitive
firm and this also introduces an idea of
deadweight loss because at least in
theory at a higher quantity people were
willing to pay more than the marginal
cost so you would you would think that
there is some type of a benefit that the
market as a whole could gain from that
incremental unit or those incremental
units and then even some more
incremental units it feels like there's
to gain but because of the what is
rational for this monopoly firm and
there's insurmountable barriers for
entry for other people to enter this is
not going to be captured until you have
this dead weight loss
now an interesting question and this is
where i started off is is what would be
the economic profit for this monopoly
firm and to think about that we have to
think about the average total cost curve
and so the average total cost i'll draw
a typical average total cost curve it
might look something
it might look something like this as
while marginal cost is below the average
total cost the average total cost
will
trend downwards and as soon as marginal
cost is higher than average total cost
well now of course average total cost is
going to start trending upwards so
marginal cost intersects the average
total cost curve at the minimum point
right over there
and so based on this average total cost
curve it looks like this monopoly firm
is earning an economic profit because at
that quantity this is the price per unit
it's getting
this is the average cost per unit so on
average per unit it's getting this
height it's getting
it's getting
it's getting this this difference right
over here and then if you were to
multiply it times the number of units
well that's going to give you its
economic profit so you could view the
economic profit in this situation as
being this shaded area of this rectangle
so i'll leave you there the big thing to
appreciate is when we're dealing with
imperfect competition in the extreme
form of a monopoly your marginal revenue
curve is no longer your demand curve and
your marginal revenue curve is downward
sloping like this it's not the flat
curve that we saw with the perfect
competition and because of that your
marginal cost is going to intersect
marginal revenue at a
quantity where price is greater than
marginal cost which introduces
deadweight loss in the market and this
and the way to think about the economic
profit is to compare what that price in
the market is of that quantity to the
average total cost at that quantity and
what's also interesting about this
monopoly firm is because of the bearish
entry we talked about in the long run
with perfect competition if there's
economic profit going on more entrants
would enter into the market but that's
not going to happen in a monopoly
because the the bearish to entry are so
high so this monopoly is sitting pretty
it's going to be able to keep earning
this type of economic profit unless
something dramatically changes in in the
market somehow